hey I'm Elle strong in this lecture is
on convective weather and convective
storms and it follows the previous
lecture I gave which was on convection
in the atmosphere so watch the
introductory lecture - convection in the
atmosphere first and then come back and
watch this and it will make more sense
but what we've said so far is that when
you look out you see a bunch of little
puffy clouds what we now know is that
underneath each one of these is a rising
plume of air and the reason the air
would want to rise is because if I look
out here I see a variety of vegetation
variety of textures a variety of terrain
and so the temperature temperatures out
here are not all the same so places
where it's warmer will want to rise
preferentially and so you get these
plumes of rising warm air that we call
thermals as they rise they expand as
they expand they cool and eventually
that air is cooled down to its dew point
and when that happens you get a
saturation of the air and the relative
humidity is a hundred percent from that
point forward you have a cloud and
whether or not the air continues to rise
just depends on whether or not it's
still warmer than the air around it so
this lecture basically focuses on the
question of what happens if this cloud
continues to grow but first let's talk
about some sources of heat so down here
the sources of heat are just simply the
the Sun but what you could have is you
could have something like maybe a fire
so we have a source of heat here and you
can see the smoke but then right here
something happens and above this point
you've got a cumulus cloud and this
cumulus cloud is a mixture now of cloud
and smoke this rising warm air expands
and cools hits the dew point right here
and you get a saturation so this is
called a pyrocumulus clouds that's a
cumulus cloud that forms over a fire now
it may seem weird that you can condense
water out of smoke but remember the air
already has
some water vapor in it and then a fire
actually adds water to the air whenever
you burn fuel whenever you burn
hydrocarbons we talked about this in the
previous lecture and adds water vapor to
the air so it's pretty common that you
get cumulus clouds forming over fires
here's another one you can see exactly
the point where temperature must equal
dew point right there we go from all
smoke below to smoke and a whiter cloud
above this is a kind of lousy video but
it's a time-lapse of a wildfire and it's
showing that you can see rising plumes
of smoke and warm air and you can see
the point where it where the air cools
until it hits the dew point temperature
it's the dew point and we get saturation
and we get clouds so you can see you
know the white is the pyrocumulus clouds
forming over the hot fire you can also
get them over volcanoes so you've got a
source of heat down here this black
material is what we call ash and ash our
tiny little fragments of rock and glass
that are coming out of the volcano but
right there you notice it changes and
you got this puffiness so this is ash
plus cloud and so as the air is rising
it's cooling and eventually the
temperature equals the dew point and you
get a cloud that's also growing in with
the ash coming out of the volcano
sometimes as humans we create clouds and
so this is an illustrate an example of
one such case think about all of the
things that we have blacktopped so big
parking lots airports we pave over large
areas with dark material and it gets
really hot so this is an example of an
Air Force Base in Florida so everyday
Sun comes up warms up the the blacktop
and that warm air starts to rise it then
condenses forms a cloud and that cloud
sits over the Air Force Base but the
wind blows it off to the side so you get
this kind of elongate cloud that goes
off into the distance so this is what it
looks like so we're standing at the Air
Force Base there's that cloud you can
see the winds blowing it off into the
distance so they basically have this
cloud that just sits there all day long
day after day after day another source
of heat our mountains and so to
illustrate this imagine that we have
mentally we don't have a mountain first
and we've got a flat terrain and as I go
up in the atmosphere I would notice that
the temperature gets cooler and cooler
and cooler and cooler with height okay
that's what you'd expect but now let's
imagine that we stick a mountain in this
okay so when the Sun comes out and warms
the earth we'll talk more about this in
a future lecture but for the most part
sunlight just travels right through the
atmosphere and doesn't affect it but it
impacts the the surface of things it
will warm them up so here you have this
surface sitting up in the air so right
here are the temperature up there is 40
degrees right here maybe when the Sun
comes up it warms it to 50 right and up
here with the temperatures 30 maybe the
Sun hits it and warms up to 40 so the
point is you've got this thing that's up
in the atmosphere that's warmer than the
atmosphere around it so what'll happen
is air will start to rise above the
mountain and if it rises enough then we
start to get condensation and a cloud
will form above the mountain so this is
what happens around here a lot so if you
live in Albuquerque a lot of times
you'll notice in the summer that will
get cumuliform clouds that start over
the Sandia's and in fact this is what it
would look like if you were to climb to
the top of a mountain and look up during
when this is happening
so right here where I'm standing looking
straight up there is warm air rising
above our heads going straight up and
then hitting the dew point you're
turning into a cumulus cause this is
what the bottom of a cumulus cloud looks
like right where the warm air rises off
the surface and so this cloud just kind
of sits to here for hours growing you
can see there's movement in here but the
cloud pretty much stays in one spot
here's another view of it so what we've
been saying so far is that you know
thermals you can't see thermals right
when the warm air rises from the surface
but this one the warm air is rising
right in front of us and so right here
you should be able to make out that the
warm air is rising right there and going
into that cloud so right there the
temperature equals dew point and you're
getting 100% relative humidity
saturation and a cloud so when you look
from space you can actually see this
effect really clearly and I've got a
satellite image here I'm at a website
called world view from NASA and right
now I'm looking down over here over New
Mexico you can go to this site if you
want if you do the date down here will
be the current date and you can change
it too so I'm looking at July 18 2017
just happen to be a day where this
happens but it but this is pretty common
well on the show here what you see is
you see that there are clouds in certain
areas and then not others right so these
areas that are kind of darker green are
higher elevation they're higher
elevation they get more precipitation
and therefore have more vegetation we'll
talk later on about why they have more
precipitation on mountains but they do
so for example here we got mountains we
get a valley
we got mountains and you can see that
the clouds are preferentially forming
over the mountains in fact we can go
down here and that gray blob right there
is Albuquerque okay so there's a
Sandhya's and you see this clouds over
the Sandia's you go a little bit to the
north as a side here you see this thing
so this is this fuzziness are ice
crystals coming off of a cumulonimbus
cloud so that's the anvil as seen from
above so this is the cumulonimbus this
is the the anvil that's spreading out
with all the ice in it in fact if I go
back down here so getting back down to
Albuquerque this one right here is
another one you can see but the
fuzziness of it and a lot of times what
will happen
is that the cumulonimbus will form over
the Sandia's and then move on and
continue to drift across the city this
time of day by the shadows I would
estimate it's probably a late morning
and so what we notice a lot of times in
the summer
is that the first clouds you'll see are
over the mountains and then once they
grow sometimes they'll drift off and go
somewhere else but they typically start
over the mountains a related idea is
what happens when you have land
surrounded by water so this is the
peninsula this is Florida right here and
so you get water on both sides of the
peninsula and you can see how many more
clouds are actually over the peninsula
than the water so we'll talk about this
in a future lecture but the ocean
doesn't change its temperature much
day-to-day and so the temperature in the
water here is pretty consistent day and
night whereas the temperatures on the on
the land vary quite a bit more between
day and night so during the day the land
heats up more than the water and you get
rising air and you get a whole bunch of
cumuliform clouds out of this so one of
the things that we are going to get into
here is try to figure out what happens
when a convection cell grows to
different heights and we have some terms
to describe how high they grow so the
same backwards but in weather when we
talk about how high a convection cell
grows we call that it's depth okay so if
I have shallow convection that means
that convective cells are not going very
high if I have deep convection that
means the cells are going much higher up
into the atmosphere
so shallow convection are days where we
might have no clouds at all the thermals
don't even get high enough to even make
a cloud or you get small cumulus clouds
deep convection you get these really
tall towering cumulus or maybe even
cumulonimbus so we're going to show you
some examples here so these are some
cumulus that are growing so we're over
the sandy as we get
a warm air rising off the mountain but
you'll notice that these cumulus don't
really grow very high right they're kind
of staying about this height and you
watch them they'll grow and they'll die
but they never get much taller than this
okay so that's pretty shallow convection
so the thermals are rising from the
surface and then they get about that
high and then they sink back down here's
another example so a lot more convection
happening in terms of plumes of warm air
rising but you'll notice that all these
things aren't very tall there's a limit
as to how tall each one these cumulus
clouds are if you watch this for a while
you'll see some of them like that one's
going to die there and then another
one's going to form so they're farming
and dying all the time as these thermals
rise hit the dew point and then cool
back down now what if we are able to
convict a little bit more and so this is
what's happening here so we might call
this moderate convection we've got a
thermal right here you can see that this
is right where the warm air is rising it
from the mountain going into the bottom
of the cloud and now the conditions are
a little different in this cloud is able
to grow vertically and it's growing a
lot more than it did in the previous
movies so we might say yeah this is
moderate convection it's it's growing
these convection cells are definitely
growing more than they did earlier
here's a another pretty significant
convection cell we might even go as far
as to call this deep convection here so
that here that the mountain again is
warm in the daytime sending up a Puma
warm air and forming this big convective
cell right above it so question is then
why is it that some days I get
convection that's deep and sometimes
it's shallow
so there's several reasons but one of
them is just simply how hot is the air
down here where it rises so some of the
earlier movies I showed you that
convective cells were very shallow it
was early in the morning they weren't
very warm yet now this one is later in
the afternoon and you can see that
they're starting to grow taller
taller so you'll see this one now notice
that fuzz there so at some point and
we'll see it again here at some point
there's some fuzz right there
these convective cells will grow tall
enough that they're going to be forming
ice crystals and if you might remember
from the cloud lecture that ice looks
fuzzy right so you can see how this
one's starting to come and make an anvil
shape a little bit but it's a different
texture right there there's some fuzz
right there so there's a nice okay so
these clouds have our mixture they're a
mixture of ice and liquid the the hard
definite boundaries that's liquid or it
starts to get more kind of fuzzy on the
edges that's ice okay and this is
important for what we're going to be
talking about next but in order to make
precipitation in order to turn a cumulus
into a cumulonimbus we have to make ice
so here's another example and again you
can see the sharp definite boundaries
here that is liquid but up here you're
starting to see see that fuzz right
there it's a little fuzzy on the edges
this is starting to make ice okay and
the ice is going to be starting to form
near the top of the cloud so one more
movie here of convection and so here see
the fuzz right through there a little
bit okay so as this thing convex you'll
see areas that will start to turn a
little bit fuzzy I carry some over here
a little bit there son right there
that's ice okay so at the top of a
really tall convecting cell you will
form ice now that ice is going to be
really important here because what's
going to happen is that ice is what's
ultimately going to be responsible for
nucleating precipitation so this is an
image that we saw in the previous
lecture and we were talking about how
the cloud droplets are actually
microscopic and rain droplets are
raindrops themselves are you know
several millimeters across and so the
question is well then how do we get
how do we go from little tiny
microscopic drops to these relatively
giant raindrops so most people have the
impression that cloud droplets will just
grow and grow and grow until they're so
big they become rain and they fall out
and it turns out that actually does not
happen it can happen in a few places
with really really high dew points like
in the tropics but where we live that
pretty much does not happen there's a
different process at work that's going
to get us from these little tiny
microscopic drops to big raindrops that
are big enough that you can you know
hold in your hand so let's imagine that
we've got one of these really tall
cumulus clouds it's got some fuzz on top
that's our ice and the ice itself would
be a little tiny microscopic particles a
little tiny crystals floating in the air
and they're gonna drift their way down
into the rest of the cloud and before we
talk about what happens next we'll talk
a little bit about how weird water
behaves in the cloud because down here
on the surface we're used to the idea
that water freezes at 32 degrees
Fahrenheit or zero degrees centigrade so
if I have a bowl of water and it's
sitting out at 32 I know that eventually
it'll completely freeze but the weird
thing is that if you have really really
really tiny microscopic droplets of
water which is what we have on clouds
because remember cloud droplets are
microscopic when they're this tiny they
have very little surface area it turns
out that what liquid water can stay in
the liquid state below the freezing
point in fact it can stay liquid all the
way down the minus 40 degrees Fahrenheit
which happens to also be minus 40
degrees centigrade
so these little droplets out in the
cloud even though the temperature is
below freezing they stay in their liquid
form and that's called supercooled water
okay so in our cloud there's actually
three zones at the top we have all ice
and the top part of the cloud is going
to be usually less than minus 40 degrees
Fahrenheit or so below that we
have what's called the mix portion of
the cloud it's ice and supercooled water
okay and by water I mean liquid right
and so then below that you know it gets
warmer as you go down we get to the part
that's all liquid and this part is going
to be above 32 right this is called the
warm part of the cloud okay so if you
were to watch what was happening up here
in this ice what you would notice is
that as the ice these little tiny
microscopic ice crystals when they drift
down into the supercooled part of the
cloud you would notice that those ice
crystals start to grow and they get
bigger and what's happening here is
another unusual process that we don't
experience in everyday life and what
happens is if you were to take ice
crystals and put them in the presence of
supercooled water so this represents the
cloud droplet and this represents the
little tiny microscopic ice crystals
floated in from above that water
molecules will preferentially attach
themselves to the ice in other words
they're actually abandoned ship they'll
leave the supercooled to liquid the
little cloud droplet and they'll attach
themselves to the ice so what happens is
the ice crystals start to grow and get
bigger as the cloud droplets become
smaller so in our cloud what happens is
this area is called the Bergeron process
that's the name for this and the
Bergeron process produces and I'm making
these way larger than they would be the
scale to the rest of the cloud but
eventually you get to something that you
might recognize because at some point
you make something that looks like a
snowflake and so these snowflakes fall
and if you were up in this part of the
cloud you think oh it's snowing and the
snow falls and it heads towards the
warmest part of the cloud and when it
passes through
to the warmest part of the cloud the
snowflakes melt and then each one of
those snowflakes melts to become a
raindrop and by the way I'm drawing
raindrops in a very incorrect manner but
every time you see rain drawn into
cartoon they're always drawn like little
teardrops but that's not that's not true
at all raindrops are actually perfectly
spherical when they fall through the
atmosphere but when they when they hit
your window they turn into a teardrop
shape so that's why everybody does that
so I'm propagating some misinformation
here but anyway these then fall out of
the cloud as precipitation and at this
point once you have precipitation
falling out of the bottom of the cloud
then you have a cumulonimbus so we can
watch this process and so let's pay
attention to this one right here so
that's a cumulus cloud right now not
really any ice to speak of it's got a
flat bottom there's air that's rising up
as thermals hitting the dew point
relative humidity a hundred percent all
that good stuff going up into the cloud
and the cloud is growing and getting
taller so this material up there will
see that that's starting to look like
some ice up there okay we're getting a
little bits of ice keep watching it here
there's a little bit of fuzz there okay
now over here that's definitely starting
to look like ice it's getting a fuzzy
edge on it and then down here if you
watch right there we're starting to see
precipitation okay so we got ice for
sure right there
we got precipitation coming out of the
bottom of the cloud there so now we've
got cumulonimbus now sometimes what
falls out of the cloud could still be
snow and the snow a melt on its way down
or sometimes it melts within the cloud
but the point is that every will every
raindrop is a melted snowflake so if it
is raining down here it's snowing up
there now if you lived in the tropics it
turns out that
this process isn't required and there
are so much water vapor in the
atmosphere in the tropics the mixing
ratios or the dew points are so high
that actually you can get direct
condensation of cloud droplets into
bigger droplets that then fall as rain
and so this is a diagram from a textbook
where it shows these coalescing cloud
droplets that become a bigger raindrop
and as it falls down it crashes into
more of them and then it'll break apart
into further ones and they will they
will come out at the bottom of the cloud
that no ice isn't necessary but where we
live and pretty much anywhere in North
America we need the Bergeron process to
make rain okay so that's pretty much
always happening in our part of the of
the world now another thing that happens
is we've been talking about up until now
we've been talking about how the clouds
have air moving up into them right we
did the whole convection activity what's
still happening with this so there's
warm air that's rising and entering the
cloud and going up into the cloud and it
forms this upgoing draft that's called
the updraft and in fact this part of the
cloud right here where they where the
air is going in is some kind of
sometimes called the intake so there's
actively air moving into the cloud now
the other thing that's happening is
we've got precipitation that's being
formed on this side so you've got
another draft that's going in the
opposite direction so you've got air
that's moving downwards and this
downward moving current is called the
downdraft
and the downdraft comes out the bottom
of the cloud with the precipitation so
if I look at a typical thunderstorm here
in Albuquerque so there is the
precipitation so the downdraft is
occurring right here we've got there
would be some kind of wind vertical wind
coming down with that the intake the
updraft is happening somewhere over here
so somewhere over here is where the air
is going up into the cloud now what can
happen is that these downdraft winds can
pick up a lot of speed for reasons we'll
discuss in a second and as they pick up
speed they come down and they come
crashing into the ground by picking up
speed
I mean we've actually measured some in
excess of 70 miles an hour comes
straight down and when they hit the
ground they splat and so you can see how
you've got rain coming straight down and
then it's like it's squishing outwards
that is wind in this kind of downdraft
we have a really strong vertical wind
associated with it it's called a
microburst so anybody that's down there
right now is not only getting rain but
it's getting a strong wind associated
with it so here's an illustration of how
that would look so remember that up in
the cloud the relative humidity is a
hundred percent so there's no
evaporation taking place as soon as
raindrops leave the leave the cloud and
go into the air column below the cloud
they're entering an environment where
the relative humidity is less than 100%
because that happens the raindrops are
subject to evaporation if you live in a
dry climate like we do you might have
really low relative humidities down here
and what that means is you get
evaporation of the raindrops as they're
falling if raindrops evaporate remember
from several lectures ago that removes
latent heat from the system see if to
imagine water molecules leaving with
their little boxes of thermal energy in
this diagram that means this air column
that's now raindrops and air and the
whole thing is being cooled by the
removal latent heat this whole column
here is becoming cold
and when you make something when you
make Eric Holder it becomes denser and
it becomes denser it sinks faster so
this whole blob becomes a sinking blob
of cold air that's accelerating towards
the surface of the earth and it hits
again like I said you hit 70 miles an
hour has nowhere to go except out and so
it produces these winds that move out in
all directions those are called the
outflow so back in our diagram here we
can add this in so if this is happening
in our in our cloud where it hits the
ground and spreads out this cold air has
a name it's called the outflow and right
at the boundary where this occurs this
is called the gust front and we'll talk
more about that in a second but right
now with the way that we've drawn this
this area right in here is where the
microburst is occurring right so if you
live right here during this you're
getting a lot of rain and a lot of wind
as well so here's an example of what we
call a wet microburst and you can tell
us a microburst because you can see it
spreading out on the edges there so
there must be some pretty strong wind
that's coming down hitting the ground
and spreading out so here's some video
footage from a microburst occurring in
Phoenix and you can see that this is the
column this is the downdraft you can
even see it moving in this and it hits
the ground and spreads out so people
that are living down there are
experiencing not only high amounts of
rain but high winds as well and you can
see it's spreading out to the side there
right so even people out here are
experiencing the outflow the wind that's
coming from this a severe thunderstorm
here's another one
from Tucson and so this one it's during
the middle of this a downpour it's going
to generate a microburst and they're
going to zoom in on it you can see it
come too
and splat against the surface down there
they'll show it a couple more times here
because here it is again so there's a
blob of cold air comes down splat and
then again so each time you see this
they're just showing the same thing over
and over but it's a particularly cold
blob of air accelerates on the way down
splats against the ground creates a high
wind that spreads out in all directions
so anybody down here is experiencing not
only rain but a sudden pretty strong
cold wind the fact this is what it looks
like from the ground in one of these and
then we're somewhere in Arizona and
we're under a thunderstorm but the
microburst hasn't started yet
there it is and we can get
hurricane-force winds you know they
don't last long but enough to do a lot
of damage they'll knock over trees and
houses and cars and all kinds of stuff
now there is another type of microburst
what we just saw was something called
the wet microburst because it's raining
at the surface or it gets wet there's
also something called a dry microburst
and we are particularly prone to these
in New Mexico and Arizona so what we're
looking at here is we got some kind of
cumulonimbus up off the screen here and
these streaks that's rain that's coming
down and it's evaporating on the way to
the surface well as its evaporating as a
as we just said you're losing latent
heat so you're making this column of air
cold and we call this vergis of vergas
whenever you have rain that just
disappears on the way to the ground so
here it is again
so there's rain that's falling is liquid
but the air column down here is pretty
dry low relative humidity you get
evaporation evaporation evaporation and
then finally there's nothing left you're
standing down here you're not getting
rained on even though the rains falling
above your head but what is happening is
the evaporation of all that rain is
removing latent heat and you're making a
column of really cold air that's really
dense and it sinks down and go splat
against the surface it just doesn't have
any water
with it we call that the dry microburst
so here's one so we can't see the
cumulonimbus that's up off the screen
here but there's a blob of invisible
cold air that has sunk down hit the
ground and you can see it's spreading
out so if you're down here the
experiences is all of a sudden it got
really windy and they heard suddenly got
colder usually here's another one it
looks like there's a look to you like
somebody just dropped something out of
the cloud and went down and went splat
that's pretty much what happened there
was some rain that came out it
completely evaporated made a blob of
sinking cold air accelerates runs into
the ground
that's all dust down there that's all
dust from the winds from the dry
microburst now microbursts can be pretty
dangerous and if I go back to this
picture that we just drew this so it's
dangerous to be down here in in the
microburst but this outflow is going to
keep going in the front of this this
gust front here I mean it can still be
moving along pretty good clip maybe so
many miles an hour or something like
that and it can do a lot of damage so a
few years ago Indiana State Fair they're
setting up for a concert and there's a
thunderstorm that's coming and you can
see in the distance there and the
thunderstorm produces a microburst which
makes the outflow the outflow wind comes
and basically invades the fair and
knocks over this whole stadium set up
and killed I think seven people and
injured about 50 or so so that is the
outflow that did that another thing that
can happen is if you have if you live in
a place that's very very dry like where
we live as this outflow is going across
the surface not only is it doing damage
just from the wind but it can be blowing
up a big cloud of dust and you
essentially make a big dust storm and
that's called a haboob it's a Arabic
term from the Middle East they get a lot
of those over there here's a picture one
and there are some famous
images in movies of who boobs from the
Phoenix area and so we got a
cumulonimbus here and it's generating an
outflow so this this whole thing is a
big blob of cold air creeping along the
surface and the as it moves across the
surface everybody that's in its way gets
covered in dust
so there's another picture of it from
above so here's a good time lapse of a
haboob again this was from Phoenix area
here it comes
you notice also that there's clouds
right above it that grow along with it
that's because as the cold air comes
along the ground it shows up the other
air out of the way and actually will
form clouds above it and sometimes will
trigger new thunderstorms here's another
one here's some excerpts from again
another YouTube clip where this guy
drives into the who boobs so here you
can see the edge of it so that would be
the guest front right along the edge and
he's going to drive right into it
because why not and as he does so you'll
see that at its peak it pretty much
looks like night and later on in the
semester we'll talk about droughts and
if you've heard about the Dust Bowl
drought in the 1930s they were dealing
with this kind of on a regular basis in
places like Oklahoma so this is the
middle of day and it's starting to look
like the middle of the night so this
might explain something that you've
experienced yourself if you live in New
Mexico you be at home it'll be a nice
clear day no clouds no wind completely
calm and all of a sudden out of nowhere
you said they're hit by this blast of
wind like where did that come from well
it could have been an outflow so what
might be happening is clerk on the other
side of the state like maybe in Carlsbad
they've got a severe thunderstorm and
they get a strong downdraft which then
turns into a strong outflow and believe
it or not the outflows can go all the
way across the state and you can track
them on radar I've tracked them on radar
all the way from Eastern New Mexico
clear into Arizona
and and so it's so far away that you
actually don't even see any clouds right
I mean the the cumulonimbus itself is
clear out of sight so that's something
that we actually experience here
especially in June and then into the
monsoon season you may experience these
outflows that just come out of nowhere
so another one of the hazards of
convective storms is that of hail and
scientists are still trying to work out
exactly how hail forms but it seems
pretty apparent that hail must have to
spend longer in the cumulonimbus cloud
than standard rain and one of the clues
is that often hail has these growth
rings so if you cut up chunk of hail
open especially a large one you'll see
these concentric rings and if you think
about what we've talked about so far
with these convective storms so the
story is you know we create a snowflake
the snowflake falls and melts and one
snowflake makes one drain raindrop which
comes out the bottom but we also have
these pretty strong down drafts and
updrafts and they're right next to each
other in the cloud so it's been
speculated that what happens if some of
these raindrops somehow got caught up in
this updraft and they have brought back
up to the top into the into the frozen
part of the cloud and then they came
back down and as they did so they would
grow another growth ring and maybe if
the conditions were right they could go
around in and around several times so
that's one idea now some of the most
recent research shows that actually
that's probably not what happens
probably what happens is that the
initial raindrop falls down and then
gets picked up and probably spend
several kind of paths back and forth up
in this supercool part of the cloud
before falling back down so it's not
necessarily a loop-de-loop as much as it
is updrafts just kind of giving it a
little push now and then to keep it in
the cloud for a little bit longer so
locally we have a pretty famous
hailstorm that occurred is
Koro 2004 and these are some pictures
from that storm as you can see there are
some you know baseball sized hail that
came down during the storm storm lasted
something like 45 minutes and these are
some pictures from people's backyards
where the hailstones just smashed
everybody's lawn furniture and New
Mexico Tech was in session so the
students come out to find their cars all
beat up like this one or something like
that and occasionally even today you'll
see a banged up car in Socorro with the
bumper sticker saying I survived the
hailstorm I also posted a document on
learn that was kind of goes over some of
the damage and some of the results from
the Socorro hailstorm here's some
pictures where the all the back windows
are broken out these are cars at New
Mexico Tech again this is when this
picture was taken it was the largest
ever measured hail stone I'm not sure if
it still is or not but this is from
Oklahoma and if you look at this it kind
of looks like a you see a bunch of
individual hailstones that are all kind
of stuck together like a conglomerate
here and the biggest hailstones
don't come from New Mexico they do tend
to come from the Midwest and we'll talk
a little bit here exactly what's going
on with that sometimes you can see the
hail come down as it's kind of bright
white it's called the hail shaft and it
looks significantly wider than normal
precipitation does of course one of the
most dangerous hazards of convective
storms is that of lightning and
lightning it turns out is not very well
understood it's very difficult to study
because it can kill you so there's a few
things that we know and it's been
observed that in a lot of thunderstorms
cumulonimbus clouds that there's an
excess of electrons in the bottom part
of the cloud and the deficiency of
electrons in the top part of the cloud
so if you have excess electrons that
means you have a negative charge down
here
you don't have enough electrons you have
a positive charge up there now
what would cause this so if you've ever
taken a balloon and you rub it on your
hair and it sticks to the wall so what
you've done there is the motion of you
rubbing it on your hair moves the
electrons from one spot to another spot
and then it gets a static charge so
remember that in the cumulonimbus right
we've got the updraft we've got the
downdraft and they're right next to each
other so it's very likely you've got
places in the cloud where you've got air
sliding past each other and maybe that's
stripping off electrons from one part of
the cloud and bringing them to another
maybe I'm probably more realistic
possibility is that if you have solid
particles like ice crystals and they
bang into each other that also strips
electrons off so it might be either one
or some of both that do this but in a
typical cloud you've got these electrons
near the bottom and you've got a
deficiency near the top and these
electrons what they want is they want to
get up to here that's where they'd like
to be well it also turns out that you've
got positive charges down here on the
ground so the earth itself has a slight
positive charge especially compared to
the bottom of this cloud well when that
charge builds up to a certain point the
electrons start coming out of the cloud
in what's called a step the leader so
this is not lightning yet it's some
ionized gas that comes out of the cloud
and these electrons don't know where
they're going so it's just kind of a
random pattern and they in the branch
and as they get closer to the ground the
positive charges that are down here you
know they were you know opposite charges
attract so they're attracted to this so
they're going to start climbing tall
things and they're going to make a
little branch
up into the air okay so these guys don't
know where these guys are these guys
don't know where those guys are but they
can sense each other and that there's a
there's a mutual attraction between the
positive and they give the charges
well eventually one of these step
leaders which again is just randomly
moving it doesn't know where it's going
will accidentally come in contact with
one of these and these are called
streamers that the positive charges from
the below so the step leader
accidentally hits a streamer and now
you've got a connection between the
excess of electrons down here and a
deficiency of electrons down there and
the result is this is actually the
lightning strike that you see so all
this step leader business that I just
drew that all happens within
milliseconds and you don't see it what
you see is when these two things touch
each other and completes the circuit and
you get lightning you get a current and
the current actually flows from ground
to cloud see if you slow down lightning
what you'll see is you will see the
lightning discharged going up into the
cloud and that's the part you see even
those fraction of a second that's what
you see and everything that came before
that is invisible to the eye now I've
got some video here that has been slowed
down a lot and we can kind of see these
stepped leaders a little bit so here's
the first one now but you'll see here
come the step leaders out of the cloud
now the grounds down here that one did
not hit the ground you can see they're
just kind of randomly shooting out they
don't know where they're going this is
not lightning yet that one came close
and all of a sudden right there one of
them hit the ground okay and that's the
actual lightning that you see okay so
I've got another one here again slowed
down a lot
here come the step leaders you can see
them coming down and then bang those two
hit the ground about the same time and
then you get a return current and that's
the lightning bolt that you actually see
now watch these two buildings those two
things those are the streamers streamers
are very difficult to photograph so we
have just a few images of them right
there I think there's one more here
right there okay so that so if you go on
YouTube you can find videos of the step
leaders coming down it's very difficult
to find footage of the streamers going
up there they're a lot harder to
photograph but we have a few now the
other thing that could happen
besides these electrons coming down and
hitting the ground is they could also in
fact get up here and join the rest of
the cloud up there right because they
just want to get to a positive charge
doesn't matter which way they do it so
you could also have if the charge builds
up you could also have a connection
between these two parts of the cloud and
you get lightning in the cloud or you
can get lightning from cloud to cloud
and in fact when people have flown
planes intentionally flown planes
through thunderstorms to study this kind
of stuff what they often find is that in
a typical thunderstorm that you might
have a pocket a positive charge in one
spot and then you'll have a pocket of
negative charge in another spot and you
can have several pockets in different
places and you'll get charging from you
know discharging I should say from one
to the other well you'll get lightning
will flash from one part of the cloud to
the other part of the cloud or from one
part of the cloud from one cloud to
another cloud so you might get lightning
from here to here you might get
lightning from here to here so not all
lightning is to the ground you can get
what's called inter cloud and
intra-cloud lightning so if you ever go
on YouTube
there's a user named Pecos Hank and he
takes just fabulous lightning movies and
he has like hundreds of these videos so
this is all intercloud and intra-cloud
lightning and you can see there's very
little lightning actually going to the
ground it's going you know from cloud to
cloud or within one part of the cloud to
another but all lightning is the same
thing its electrons want to get from one
place to another and when the charge
builds up high enough they can finally
break down the air and make their own
path and that's what creates the
lightning bolt so associated with
lightning is Thunder and the lightning
bolt itself is about six to eight inches
wide and so that during that brief
instant when electricity is flowing
through the lightning bolt you've got
this six to eight inch air column that's
being heated to thousands of degrees and
when you heat air air expands so what
that means is as the lightning is
happening the air in that column is
being pushed out because it's so hot but
then when the lightnings over with
there's nothing to keep that air column
hot and so the lightnings over with
there's a very little air in here and
it's like a vacuum and the surrounding
air slaps that call them back together
and that's what makes thunder so every
time you have lightning it's generating
thunder now thunder moves at the speed
of sound and the speed of sound is it
can go about one mile every five seconds
so when you see a flash in the distance
if you start counting
one-mississippi two-mississippi
three-mississippi then when you hear the
thunder you will know how many miles
away that lightning is right so if you
count to 15 seconds then it's about
three miles away now a kind of a weird
thing happens if you're over 20 or so
miles away it kind of depends on the
conditions but it turns out sound waves
when they travel long distances they
refract upwards and if you're over 20
miles from from a lightning storm you
will actually hear
the Thunder it's actually moved up and
refracted over your head and I get this
question sometimes from students asking
me about heat lightning and this is kind
of a folklore that there's certain kind
of lightning that you can't hear but
that's not true
all lightning makes thunder but if
you're too far away from it you just
don't hear it so you see flashes in the
distance but you never hear the Thunder
so we've been talking about all kinds of
hazards associated with the downdraft
right we talked about the outflow and
the haboob and all that stuff there's
also some hazards associated with the
updraft and one of them is quite simple
which is that if you are in an
ultralight aircraft or a balloon or
parachuter you don't want to get too
close to this cloud because you could
literally get sucked up into the cloud
and there's an aviation term for this
it's called cloud suck and so cloud suck
is a real thing and occasionally people
get sucked up into the clouds when they
don't want to be kind of a famous
accident in 1925 this is a blimp the
shenandoah and it got too close to one
of these convecting clouds got sucked up
in it and crashed and if you pay
attention to the news every once in a
while you will run across people who
have been sucked up into clouds during
uh you know hang gliding or paragliding
almost always they die this woman
somehow or another lived and apparently
she got sucked up into a cloud
immediately went unconscious spent like
an hour in that in this cloud I was
covered in ice and somehow or another
survived all this but most people do not
of course the most common hazard of the
intake or the updraft is the tornado and
if conditions are right and you have
really strong convection the intake the
updraft actually can start forming a
tornado and I just loved this video
because this guy he's actually driving
towards the tornado and this is one of
the cleanest views I've ever seen of a
tornado it's so much so that it kind of
looks fake right like if you saw that in
a movie you
being that that's fake so in order to
get a tornado you need some very
vigorous convection you need very
unstable air but you also need a couple
other things one thing you need is
something called wind shear and when
shear means that the wind is blowing
stronger above your head than it is near
the surface and what that does is it
makes the air near the ground kind of
spin in a circle right then you've got
thermals so what we talked about except
the thermals now are going to push that
spinning air upwards and if it does it
just right you can take that spinning
air and reorient it vertically and then
the air intake the updraft is spinning
and you get a tornado now if you look at
tornadoes across the country there's
definitely a spot that is weather far
more common we call this Tornado Alley
and it's kind of centered here in
Oklahoma and so we're gonna talk a
little bit about why this is before I do
notice that you know the tornadoes looks
like in this map they completely stop
right there that's not entirely true
here's another way that you can look at
tornadoes so this is 56 years of tornado
tracks everyone these blue lines and
again like most of them are out here and
something is causing them to stop right
around here but they don't completely go
away and you can see there's a little
blue lines all over the place here where
there have been tornadoes so imagine if
we just cut the country right in half
right through here right through Tornado
Alley and we kind of looked at it from
the side so we make what's called a
cross-section right through the country
and we got south to the right north to
the left what kind of air is over here
off in other words if we went south of
the country where do we end up we end up
in the Gulf of Mexico right so what's
the air from there like well it's going
to be very warm and gonna have very high
dew points right so a lot of water in
that air air from the north is coming
down from Canada
and it's going to be very cold and very
dry yes we got cold and dry coming from
the north so if these two air masses
come together there's going to be a
place kind of in the middle where you
have warm air on the bottom and you have
cold air on top now if you remember from
the convection assignment we had one
page where you you drew the clouds and
they went up a certain height and then
you went to the next page and we had
cold air aloft and the clouds grew up
off the page well that's kind of what's
happening here because you've got warm
air on the bottom and cold air on the
top it's very easy for this warm air to
convict upwards and you get really tall
big strong cumulonimbus clouds and where
do these two meet typically they meet
right around Oklahoma so if I go back to
this map I can imagine I've got warm
humid air from the Gulf of Mexico coming
from the south I got cold dry air coming
from the north they kind of meet up in
here so what so why doesn't it happen
over here well the Rocky Mountains form
a barrier for us us meaning us in New
Mexico for the most part the the edge of
the mountains prevents the cold air from
coming down it kind of keeps it on the
side of the mountains and it keeps the
warm human air also on the side of the
mountain so these mountains really kind
of keep both of those pools of air away
from us and so we don't have much you
know we don't have a lot of really in
stable air and we don't have really
severe thunderstorms in this part of the
country compared to over here in Tornado
Alley
so that's all we're going to talk about
with convective storms I'm gonna leave
you with some time lapse of some
convective cells and next time we're
going to talk about wind and air
pressure and how those two things are
connected thanks I'll see you next time
you